[Music]
in dangerous saliva news submitted by
airplane safety videos woman lost her
hands and legs after an infection from a
dog with this is the thing I've told you
my mom was talking about what she's
talking about
this is starting what she's saying oh so
my moms at that age now where she's so
she's retired my dad passed so she
doesn't have her life partner so she's
very alone and she's at that point now
where she's like every little thing she
holds on to she she doesn't know she
doesn't have someone to let it out with
so she tells me all these things all the
time
and I love her to death but after why
you're just like oh really what else
happened mom so this one she taught me a
lot so I'd like to be a husband it's
pretty rugged it's my mom
but because my dad doesn't want to hear
it she's here
yeah so then I have to like like [ __ ]
up for me to just be like oh haha I'm
like Oh what kind of breed was a dog I
do nothing is it that crazy Wow you know
this whole story you could take over I
don't want to hear it it's rough you
should just say shut up mom no I love
her though okay like I was at the gas
station and the handle was completely
ripped off and in that and I might go
yeah yeah oh well how much gas did you
get
what was the prices yeah yeah and you
have to entertain it okay conversation
yeah it's 3:24 gone you know across the
street is 338 really that's crazy dude
which one did you go - I went to the
shell yeah I normally go to the Mobil
station but I was gonna do it today how
are you what are you already outside of
your car
oh yeah I'll get back in well first the
seatbelt got stuck getting now it's all
real - it's all what I do I just send my
mom on cruises then the phone call stop
just send her on cruises man oh yeah you
see the phone ringing like send her on a
cruise
tele
John Julia do you like you book my mama
Cruise yeah can you just the Caribbean
this time a thirty day cruise and then
now your mom caught on to the pattern
that's where she causes you so much yeah
you got played jokes oh well as long as
he's happy alright so this story here
it's about Marie she so initially she
went to this vacation in Punta Cana and
so she came back with a backache and
nausea and so and also her temperature
started going up like it would go up and
down up and down damn Mexican dogs and
Mexican yeah who said it was in Mexico
in Mexico it's a Mexican resort huh you
said it was a Mexican accent yeah that's
Dominican Republic isn't it right oh
they're the island Mexico no they're the
Dominican Republic yeah it's it's a it's
like the Hawaii of Mexico no but it's
just black people there this means like
I was trying to have you back your whole
[ __ ] time I might not looked yeah we
go down together over here anyway you
have no choice so [ __ ] that frame on
that side okay so she ended up going to
emergency room in her home in Ohio and
that's when she woke up in bed nine days
later with her hands and her legs
amputated [ __ ] wait wait wait so she
went to sleep and she woke up with her
hands gone yep so what happened was she
was sleeping let me tell you girl so
what happened was look that sucks
yeah so it took the doctor seven days to
discover that she had a severe infection
and not from that tropical travel
disease that they first suspected but it
was from her German Shepherd licking for
Oh what yeah her own dog so she got this
rare infection from this bacteria that
came from her puppy licking and
open-cut to serve puppy blow I mean
puppies leva yeah yeah we got to get rid
of our dogs of German shepherds well we
can't have them lick our wounds do you
ever do that you ever get a cut you go
back in the day I would let him yeah
that's right it is I heard in their
saliva that special neosporin too but I
guess if the dogs infected we don't know
if the dogs and that's like voodoo [ __ ]
medicine stuff I love it our dogs have
healing properties with their licks
there were studies that showed her maybe
we read some jenkki news articles with
it that would see the dogs like saliva
was really clean I think it's for
themselves oh oh no it's very clean
that's true bacterially it's our mouth
that's why I was just like go for it
dude take it away but don't cuz that's
what happened here so yeah they're
saying that it was really difficult to
identify
oh so it's really gross so what happened
was when she went to the ICU
that's when she became unconscious her
skin tarted started changing rapidly to
a purplish red color and then it
progressed into gangrene oh no no she
developed a blood clot yeah so then she
they had to narrow it down and this
infection had spread to the tip of her
nose her ears legs and her face she
didn't lose part of her face she's got
the cutting of that stuff off no but her
extremities had - oh so I went through
her blood everywhere on him so wait did
she get the doggie lick before the
vacation and then she came back and in
hey it was like symptoms or after the
vacation I'm assuming it happened after
the vacation because it progressed so
rapidly how many days did you say 97
I mean on the ninth day but it took
seven days for them so the dog was
infected with something yeah that was
the bacteria he was created that's crazy
you'd never know cuz we did a jakey news
about this guy he was taking out the
trash and a little bit of that trash
juice got into his leg and had a [ __ ]
a beating yeah
so they're saying that this particular
bacteria it's really rare to cause
illness in humans but people with weaker
immune
systems such as cancer patients or
people have had their spleens removed
will contract this so she was already
weak I don't know what her her condition
was beforehand but can you imagine the
patient hearing that [ __ ] from the
doctor like usually no one gets hey just
so you know it's rare it's very rare and
you wake up with no arms and legs you're
the winner so you get this man I should
go to Vegas right now look at how lucky
I am I know she had like a cut too or
something so that's how it's true well
that is that is how she got it oh my god
who licked the cut oh yeah the dog
doesn't happen doesn't suffer from Ed
this disease no they just pass it yeah
what did they do to the dog so she ended
up asking she requested for her dogs to
come and visit her in the hospital
because she didn't blame the dog it was
just like what it's literally the dog so
what my dog starts licking back this
just up on there and just like so much
to lose maybe that's what she's thinking
there's think she's saying that her and
her husband like have no plans on oh my
god but she's like oh she's susceptible
to the husband I still got my arms and
legs I'm getting those dogs the [ __ ] out
yeah I would - I [ __ ] love dogs you
guys know me but I'd be like you're
gonna kill me dog I love you let me put
you in a great happy home no mas a great
happy home with the people I hate the
most
you guys don't like me uh my dad and I
were cool my bad dog aids or something
that's so [ __ ] sad and this is you
know both legs a bulk heart I told you I
thought it was one of them no both oh
look how happy everyone else my god
that's a supportive ass family dude
talking God that is crazy
oh she can't even pet the doggy anymore
that dogs cute though that's like that
is a cute guy but the doggy looks like a
like a wolf more than a German Shepherd
maybe it's like a mixie yeah so they're
saying that
um that particular bacteria has had been
detected in up to 74 percent of dogs
according to the CDC and animals can be
tested for it but the results can change
so fun meow walk
there's something about 3 and 10 people
who have developed a severe infection
have died yeah that's a lot 30 percent
yeah I won't touch any dogs now I'm
scared
well just don't get cutted yeah no my
immune system sucks oh oh was it will
they make it better coffee you get to
give oh four times a year
oh yeah that's precise every four months
yeah
oh wow do you have seasonal depression
well you said your sleeping is bad how
many hours are getting sleep oh not too
bad depends really feels all judge now
doctors good ain't no you should be
learning nine should be better nine yeah
one more hour for you yeah a lot of
chicken broth maybe you need collagen
we're crazy
now this born with I think is born with
a bad knee system and this person I met
with that immune system yeah people I
know are like so resilient they could
have the flu and then like give it to
somebody else and then not be sick
anymore the next day she's pointing out
being not actually be the music oh yeah
we don't think of you mean yeah you
might be a little bit Chinese French
took over more yeah you get a bowl of
thawed a mango and then you should be
cured she that's what you're
stereotyping gets you I'm like mangoes
my coconut I feel like oh yeah coconut
juice yeah yes true that's true
got the wrong stereotype that have you
been have you been to Vietnam I have
yeah like three years ago
did you get sick when you went no I
didn't actually I was just like when I
went to Barcelona Oh
food poisoning oh that Spanish food
yeah that damn Spanish you got on that
they're already down there alright so
anyway back to the story so there's been
a go fund me page to raise nearly twenty
thousand dollars and a pool tournament
fundraiser for Murray
yeah so like Dillard's
yeah so their son is trying to like
there there's no billiards is it
billiards
I don't know oh my bed I hate to correct
that it's so stupid but I couldn't let
it slide because of the previous video
were you called me out so where are we
when I was giving you a compliment I
know but I was in this petty it was a
compliment
that is really your bippy not like
mispronouncing something no no no I've
got I've noticed that you just counted
them yeah you piece of [ __ ] no no no no
it's it's if I need to get revenge on
somebody you like use anything then I'll
use anything yes oh but then you're
assuming that it affected me but I don't
care so you're gonna still hold it too
long but nobody it feels like I got a
piece of my soul back okay yeah Murray
here we can cut that was perfect whiskey
filler here that was great
we can cut
[Music]